(cloches)
- Phil Fontaine est
en territoire plutôt connuau Vaf
de l'Assemblée des Premières
Nations n'en est pas
à une première visite
du Saint-Siège; demain
sera sa troisième rencontre
avec le pape.
Les rencontres à Rome
et l'importante attention
médiatique qui leur sont
portées confirment aussi,
il Fontaine,
que la question du rôle de
l'Église dans les pensionnats
dépasse maintenant
les frontières du Canada.
Lors de sa dernière visite
en 2009, Benoit XVI avait
exprimé de la tristesse à propos
du traitement déplorable
des enfants autochtones
dans les pensionnats, mais
n'avait pas offert d'excuses.
Sauf qu'après les découvertes
de 215 sépultures anonymes
d'enfants à Kamloops, mais
aussi la Commission de vérité
et réconciliation et l'Enquête
nationale sur les femmes
et les filles assassinées
et disparues, bien des vérités
ont été étalées au grand jour.
Mandy G Mandy G Mandy G Mandy e
les découvertes de Kamloops ont
été un point tournant, et pas
seulement pour les Autochtones.
MANDY GULL-MASTY, grande chef,
Grand Conseil des Cris- C'est ls
que j'ai vraiment vu dans
les nouvelles un message
de support, de réalisation
de ce qui s'est passé.
- Si des excuses du pape
sont tant attendues, c'est que
les pensionnats ne sont pas non
plus qu'une affaire du passé.
Première femme élue grande
cheffe du Grand Conseil
des Cris, elle souligne
à quel point l'impact de
ces institutions faites pour
assimiler les Autochtones se
font encore sentir aujourd'hui.
- J'ai vraiment eu...
une relation difficile
avec ma mère et ma grand-mère.
Il y avait comme un... un "gap"
entre nous. Puis moi, les choses
que j'ai vécues à cause des
impacts du "residential school",
ça s'implique dans ma relation
avec eux autres.
- Les représentants autochtones
sont à la recherche d'excu
mais ils veulent aussi obtenir
du concret. Mandy Gull-Masty
et d'autres veulent maintena
que toutes les archives
des pensionnats que
possèdent les dio
leur soient remises.
- On manque beaucoup
d'information concernant
les personnes qui ont étudié
à ces écoles, puis je dis
"étudier", mais qui se sont
faits envoyer à ces écoles.
- Le président de la conférence
des évêques du Canada répond que
l'Église est ouverte à le faire.
Raymond Poisson sait surtout
que les attentes e
le pape seront grandes,
mais il est convaincu que
le chef de l'Église prononcera
les bons mots vendredi.
Mgr RAYMnt,
Confér. évêques catho. Canada
- J'ai totalement confiance
qu'il va dire quelque chose
de très clair et de très direct
à l'enses personnes
qui sont venues de si loin
pour le voir.
- Phil Fontaine et
les Autochtones
attendent depuis longtemps
des excuses. Après des décennies
de combat, cette fois-ci
ourrait enfin être la bonne.
Ici Mathieu Gohier,
Radio-Canada, Rom